the world of The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt is
beautiful and terrible and mad it is
perhaps a cliche to point out something
so obvious but even when facing the
harshness of nature in the roar of a
giant beasts intent on seeing you dead
its humankind that proves the truest
monsters well this being a fantasy world
we can include dwarf kind elf kind and
so forth as well who dares disturb my
cavorting beard
Geralt of Rivia pleasure in this game
series final major chapter Geralt isn't
just plunging his silver sword into
necker's and drowners he's also facing
harsher truth there's practically no one
you can trust in a world where people
are this desperate desperate to live
desperate to thrive desperate for
control desperate for even a tiny sliver
of hope amid the constant misery
you will feel their pain it's hard not
to physical pain is revealed on
characters expressive faces many or most
of which are criss-crossed by scars you
hear emotional pain in people's cries of
suffering and experience it in pleading
conversations even the simplest killing
contracts which see you slaying
screeching raids and flying behemoths
are not so simple
those monsters represent the loss of
loved ones in the squelching of dreams
the one you abandoned remember the
writing is both rich and profane getting
into the heart of every citizens deep
rooted troubles and few quests are
accomplished in a single step murdering
monsters isn't just about swinging your
weapon but about revealing the anguish
that invited it to dwell oh and it's
also about using your keen Witcher
senses to reveal objects of interest and
the scent trails of monsters and
witnesses alike but misery is apparent
not just with random citizens of this
gigantic and captivating open world but
with Geralt and his returning associates
Triss Merigold is hiding in the city of
novigrad where mages and their
associates are parked at the stake the
bard dandelion is God knows where and
solving the mystery of his whereabouts
is no quick task you are reunited with
former lover yennefer who was only
mentioned in previous games and she's as
wracked by grief as you are by the
disappearance of ciri the young woman
the two of you raised as your own series
at the heart of this story though
finding her is only part of your primary
goal how awful and wonderful all of
these struggles turn out to be the
witcher 3 is one of the best open-world
role-playing games ever made sullied
mainly by the bugs that occasionally
intrude you might break a particular
quest by performing tasks in an
unexpected order or run into a hard
crash or two or notice a number of
visual
inches I'd say The Witcher 3 falls
within acceptable bounds when it comes
to the bugs and occasional performance
quirks of a giant open-world RPG though
of course your mileage might vary but
what are these elements in light of such
an achievement
it's a lush and terrible world out there
and while icons on your map lure you to
them to see what treasures and secrets
might be found there it's the very
thrill of discovery that pulls you into
the wilderness every derelict temple
every circle of worshippers every cave
mouth cries out to be explored in part
because none of these things could be
accused of copy/paste design sure the
basics boil down to killing retreating
and activating your Witcher senses but
even the smallest of adventures have a
sense of uniqueness and the treasures
are numerous enough that you look
forward to seeing what weapon diagram or
hastily scribbled letter you might find
a letter that leads you to even more
loot and uncovered secrets loot has a
huge role to play in the game thanks to
the high degree of customization of your
armor and in your weaponry different
armor sets in particular are a joy to
uncover making Geralt look more and more
hardened as you progress The Witcher 3
also benefits from its hugely expanded
potion system which allows you to quaff
potions during combat though of course
which your potions are dangerous and
Geralt can only have so many in effect
before he succumbs to their toxicity
suffice it to say that the game is huge
I spend close to a hundred hours with
The Witcher 3 yet my map was still
loaded with stuff to do and luckily you
get the chance to pursue those quests
and monsters after the credits roll of
course big isn't necessarily a good or a
bad thing it's just a thing but this
world is aching with violent beauty
begging you to take in every nook the
joy of exploration is furthered by the
game's perfect content balance providing
you with icons to chase while still
allowing other surprises to appear
organically in this way both you and the
world get to breathe and the intrigue
builds naturally
every quest is a story of sadness or
triumph waiting to absorb you asking you
to make decisions that change the
landscape in small and large ways you
won't always know what the consequences
are some decisions have noticeable game
altering repercussions while others
barely divert your gaze but the
consequences are there and you often
notice them even though the game doesn't
go out of its way to call them out and
force you to admire them don't get me
wrong I'm grateful but everything I had
I just lost
you need to pull out both your steel and
silver swords from time to time whether
to fight off bandits or bruisers of the
political factions you piss off or to
destroy the incredible looking monsters
to plague the land The Witcher threes
combat is more fluid than The Witcher
twos and the branching upgrade paths
make magical signs far more important
and enjoyable to perform than before by
diversifying and altering their
behaviors the game is also noticeably
easier than its predecessor and because
it's so easy to out level story quests
by getting caught up by side quests and
monster contracts you should probably
consider in choosing a difficulty
setting one notch higher than you
normally would but even when things get
easy the combat is always satisfying due
to the crunchiness of landing blows the
howls of human foe scorched by your igni
sign and the fearsome behavior of
necrophagous wandering ghosts and
lumbering werewolves The Witcher 3 the
Wild Hunt is incredible it may be filled
with nonhumans but it tells a remarkably
human story even as the world's politics
bubble and burst around you on scales
both big and small where The Witcher 2
sort of sputtered to a halt The Witcher
3 is always in crescendo crafting battle
scenarios that constantly one-up the
last and in between those battles you
get caught up in the heartbreaks and the
triumphs and the never ending conflict
between the sacred and the profane
but a video game can capture the
violence of battles no surprise that it
can so movingly depict the life
shattering tragedies and messy
opportunities that arise in vicious x is
the Whichard threes greater victory